- [Devon] This episode of Real Law Review
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking the link in the description.
Rapper 2 Milly, Alfonso
Ribeiro, aka Carlton Banks,
and The Backpack Kid are
suing the makers of Fortnite,
the world's most popular video game,
for stealing their dance moves.
You cannot make this up.
But can you copyright a dance?
In today's Real Law
Review, it's a dance-off.
(upbeat music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, welcome
back to Real Law Review.
As always, subscribe for
more cutting edge analysis
and stay until the end, when I give you
my prediction for who will
win this ridiculous lawsuit.
But let's start at the beginning.
Can you even copyright a dance?
Well, the answer, believe
it or not, is yes.
Although dance is an art form
that is as old as time itself,
copyright protection for dance,
specifically choreography,
is a recent development.
Being able to copyright dances
is a relatively recent development
which was codified in 1976 when Congress
changed the Copyright Act to include
choreography and pantomime
to the list of things
that you could actually copyright.
Congress defined choreography as
the composition and arrangement
of a related series of
dance moves and patterns
in an organized, coherent whole.
So, on the question of whether
you can actually copyright dances,
the answer is sometimes, yes.
And the dances in question
here look very similar.
If I had to guess, it looks
like the makers of Fortnite
basically copied 2 Milly's
dance frame for frame.
You can see here that the
dances are almost identical
and that goes for Alfonso
Ribeiro's Carlton dance as well.
You can see that it is very, very similar
to the dance that you can
buy in the game Fortnite.
And of course, Backpack
Kid's short dance move
is basically the same here as well.
And there are other dances in Fortnite
that you can buy as downloadable content
that also look very, very
similar to other artists.
For example, there is the
Poison Dance from Scrubs
that was created by Donald Faison
that's basically the same, move
for move in the game itself.
So, it seems pretty clear here
that the makers of Fortnite
are trying to make a profit
off of the dances that were
created by other people.
But just because the
dances are almost identical
does not mean that it's
copyright infringement.
First, a little background
on copyright law in general.
How do you get copyright protection?
Well, you have to have original expression
that is fixed into a tangible medium.
Here, video counts as a tangible medium,
so if you record a dance into video,
that's actually one of the preferred ways
of copyrighting a potential dance,
so that's not really an issue.
But you should know that copyright
does not apply to ideas themselves.
Only the actual expression.
And you can't copyright functional things,
that's what patent protection is for.
And courts have interpreted
the Copyright Clause
of the Constitution as
requiring minimal creativity
in addition to originality.
Originality is the bedrock
principal of copyright
It requires that to qualify
for copyright protection,
a work must be original to its author,
and that means that that work must be
independently created by the author itself
and it must possess at least
some minimal degree of creativity.
So, for example, you can't copyright
a single note or a single word,
but you can string a series
of those notes together
to make a copyrightable song
and you can string together
a series of uncopyrightable
words to form an original book.
But there is absolutely
no bright line rule
that says it requires this many words
to form a copyrightable phrase or a book
or it requires this many notes
to be a copyrightable song.
Certainly, there are very short songs
and very short literary works
that despite being very, very small,
still qualify for copyright expression.
So, it is an open question
as to how many dance moves
you have to string
together in order to form
a copyrightable dance choreography.
So, for the purposes of this discussion,
I'm going to assume that these dances
are original to these authors
who are filing this lawsuit,
but it may very well not be the case.
Of course, I am no expert in dance.
Anyone who has ever seen
me dance at a wedding
knows that that is absolutely the case.
But to me, these are the kinds of dances
that may very well be
products of popular culture
and merely popularized by
the various entertainers
who are filing suit here,
which would basically doom
their copyright claims,
if they weren't the original author.
But for the purposes of this video,
let's assume that they are
original for copyright purposes.
And I will also note that there is footage
of Alfonso Ribeiro where he claims
that he stole his particular Carlton dance
from Courtney Cox and combined that with
some dance moves with Eddie Murphy.
- [Interviewer] How did it originate?
Was it just like, one of your dances
that you did when you were younger
and you're like, "No, I'm bringing it."?
- No, on the Fresh Prince,
they basically had a script
where it said, you know, "Carlton dances"
and I went, "Alright, well
how would Carlton dance?"
and I said, "You know
what, I know exactly.
"I'm gonna steal it."
(others laugh)
I stole it from Courtney Cox
[Interviewer] Okay.
- and Eddie Murphy.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
Is it a combination of both of those?
- It's a combo of all of that
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- with a little bit of me mixed in.
- [Interviewer] Awesome.
- You know?
- Now, that is certainly
not the kind of statement
that I would want a client to make
in the context of a copyright suit,
but it doesn't necessarily doom his claim
because, again, a song is
always going to be made up
of noncopyrightable
notes to form a melody.
So, just because there
are constituent parts
that might not be copyrightable,
sometimes, and there's a big caveat there,
sometimes when you add
those things together,
you can create an individual work
that is original on its own
or sometimes, they
qualify as a compilation.
But, that being said, it's
not a great statement.
It just doesn't necessarily doom his case.
Now, before I dig into the actual lawsuits
that have been filed and the
dance moves at issue here,
there's one last thing I need to tell you
as it regards copyright of
dances and choreography,
which is that when the House
passed the 1976 Copyright Act,
it issued a report along
with the act itself
to clarify some of the
changes that it made.
And in that House report,
Congress specified
that choreographic words do not include
social dance steps and simple routines.
Thus, for example,
Congress exempted things
like the basic waltz
step, the hustle step,
the second position of classical ballet.
All of those things are not copyrightable.
But Congress also specified that this
is not a restriction
against the incorporation
of social dance steps and simple routines
into an otherwise larger
choreographic work.
The Second Circuit,
which is one step below
the Supreme Court, in the
Horgan versus MacMillen case,
held that social dance
steps, folk dance steps,
and individual ballet
steps may be utilized
as the choreographer's basic material,
much in the same way that words
are the writer's basic material.
So, at issue here are several lawsuits
that were filed by the rapper 2 Milly,
Alfonso Ribeiro, and Backpack Kid.
They all seem to be represented
by the same law firm
and they're all filing
suit in the federal court
in Los Angeles, the Central
District of California,
where I've practiced many, many times.
And in those lawsuits,
the performs are alleging
that the makers of Fortnite
and a number of other
video game developers
have basically stolen all
of the different dances
to include them in downloadable content
from which they make a profit
and that that qualifies
as copyright infringement.
They are fairly bare bones
complaints, but they do seem
to state the essential elements
for copyright infringement.
So, given that the dances in question here
are basically identical,
the main legal issue
is whether the dances are social dances
or whether they are choreographic works.
In other words, are these dances
copyrightable in the first place?
Now normally, I would
just look up the case law
and look for cases that
have interpreted the phrase
"Social dances in the Copyright Act"
and compare them to cases that have
interpreted choreographic works
and give you an easy answer as to
whether the dances in question
qualify as social dances or not.
Unfortunately, there
are very, very few cases
that have dealt with this language.
Again, this is a very new aspect
of the Copyright Law in general
and really very few people
have even litigated this.
There's basically one case on point,
and that, again, comes out of
the Central District of California,
which is where a lot of
copyright law originates
because that's where Hollywood is.
Basically, the only court case
to deal with this language
is the court case of Bikram
Yoga versus Evolution Yoga,
which dealt with a
sequence of 26 yoga poses.
And the issue there was
whether the yoga poses
would qualify as a copyrightable
work, a choreographic work,
or whether they were
non-copyrightable in the first place.
The court sided with the defendants,
stating that the 26 yoga poses, quote,
"Hardly seems to fall
within the definition
"of pantomime or choreographic work
"because of the simplicity of the sequence
"and the fact that it is not
a dramatic performance.".
However, the plaintiff
appealed to the 9th Circuit
and while the 9th Circuit agreed
that the defendants should win,
they did not agree on the
basis for that decision.
And the 9th Circuit held that
the sequence of yoga moves
was not copyrightable not because
it wasn't a choreographic work,
but because it was a demonstration
of an idea, process, or system
to which copyright protection
may in no case extend.
So, given that this is a
matter of first impression,
where the courts really haven't weighed in
on what constitutes copyright infringement
in the context of a
dance or a choreography,
who's going to win these law suits?
Well, let's think like a lawyer.
(hard rock music)
So, here's what I think both
sides are going to argue.
First, the plaintiffs are going to argue
that these dances are very, very unique.
They're instantly recognizable.
If you see someone
performing the Carlton dance,
you know that that is the Carlton dance
that appeared on The
Fresh Prince of Bel Air.
And the fact that they are
so unique and so recognizable
shows that they should
get copyright protection
despite the fact that
they are very, very short.
And just in the same way that you can
string together uncopyrightable notes
to form a copyrightable song,
you can string together
uncopyrightable moves,
movement in the air, to
form a copyrightable dance.
And it would be weird to make dance
less copyrightable than its counterparts
in the literary or musical world.
I think that the defendants would counter
by saying that these are not
minimally creative or unique.
These are just standard dance moves
that you'll see anywhere, like
a scènes à faire or a trope.
That they are just putting together
what people have been doing
for a very, very long time.
And most important, I think
the defendants would argue
that the dances in
question are social dances
and therefore, not copyrightable.
They are far more akin to
the foxtrot or the waltz
than they are to an
entire hour-long ballet,
a work of choreography, that was intended
to receive copyright protection.
In my own personal view, as someone
who has litigated many,
many copyright issues,
I think the defendants have
the better argument here.
To me, if the phrase social dance,
the exception to the Copyright Clause,
is meant to have any meaning whatsoever,
I think it's meant to include
the dances at issue here.
I think that Congress intended to create
a differentiation between
a large choreographed work
and just a social dance like the waltz.
Maybe the Macarena would qualify as well.
And I think these short dances
would qualify as social dances
that were meant to be performed in public
as opposed to being a copyrighted work.
After all, we don't want copyright law
to allow artists to sue anyone performing
their dance moves in public,
wherever the young people are
performing their dance moves.
Clubs, sock hops, I don't know.
Wherever you people hang out.
So, this is untested
and could go either way,
but I think that the
defendants are likely to win
as a matter of law.
But because this is a
matter of first impression,
the courts really haven't
weighed in on this
and there are reasonable
arguments on either side.
The courts could go either way.
The law is constantly evolving
and I'll be fascinated to
see how this one turns out.
And if you want to create
your own copyrightable choreography,
first, you need to learn how to dance.
I would recommend Emeroy
Bernardo's Skillshare classes
on basic hip hop dancing,
where you'll learn
the basics of modern
dance and how to dance
to people like Justin
Timberlake and Drake,
two artists who have never sued
your favorite game developer.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000
classes on everything,
like lifestyle, design, and technology.
The first 500 Legal Eagles
to click on the link below
will get two free months of Skillshare.
The free premium membership gives you
unlimited access to must-know topics,
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things,
like learning how to
dance better than I can.
So, click the link, get two
free months of Skillshare,
and start learning today.
So, until next time,
I'll see you in court.